you know those three four days afterward  i was miserable i really really was it  took some time to like kind of get out  of that funk so when you say you're  miserable how did that like manifest in  your day-to-day it's just tough like  sometimes i come off so laid back that i  don't know if people understand how much  i invest into this game how much i care  how hard i work i'm not like the loudest  or you know may show everything but it  was just so tough because i literally  gave everything that i had to feel like  i ran out that i didn't have anything  left to give and we were so close didn't  have appetite i didn't want to talk to  anybody i didn't want to go anywhere i  just was like in my house for like three  four days straight